Save now at Whole Foods Market. It's the Summer Splash event, with great everyday prices on 365 brand ground beef for the grill and ice cream for dessert. They have yellow sales signs on ready to cook beef or chicken kebabs too. Level up with savory marinate, spices and rubs, and complete your cookout with a crowd-pleasing cherry pie and their balsamic chicken salad. Available at the prepared foods counter. Get Summer Splash Savings now at Whole Foods Market. Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a bi-weekly podcast from the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna.
现在就去全食超市（Whole Foods Market）省钱吧。夏季清凉活动正在进行中，365品牌的烧烤用碎牛肉和餐后甜点冰淇淋都有超值的日常优惠。他们还在待烹饪的牛肉或鸡肉烤串上贴了黄色促销标签。用美味的腌料、香料和干擦料来提升口感，再配上一份广受欢迎的樱桃派和香醋鸡肉沙拉，让你的户外烧烤更加完美。这些都可以在熟食柜台买到。现在就去全食超市享受夏季清凉优惠吧。您好，欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的一档双周播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。
Fear about the coronavirus has gripped the world. As I speak, more than 600 people have died from the virus and more than 31,000 people have become sick. That's according to the World Health Organization. Nearly all cases have been in China, but that hasn't stopped people in other countries from worrying. Here in the U.S., a dozen or so people have become ill so far. While this new illness certainly is frightening and needs attention, it's important to note that far more people die from an illness that's all too familiar, the seasonal flu.
对冠状病毒的恐惧已经席卷全球。就在我说话的时候，已有超过600人死于该病毒，超过31,000人患病。这是根据世界卫生组织的数据得出的。几乎所有的病例都发生在中国，但这并没有阻止其他国家的人们感到担忧。在美国，到目前为止已有十几人患病。虽然这种新疾病确实令人恐惧，需要引起重视，但值得注意的是，死于一种我们非常熟悉的疾病——季节性流感的人数要多得多。
An estimated 10,000 people have died from it this year in the U.S., according to the Centers for Disease Control, and 19 million have become sickened. Why are we so afraid of this novel coronavirus when we are much more likely to catch the flu? Our guest for this episode will explain why we worry about new risks more than familiar ones, how to calm our anxiety, and what are the psychological effects of being quarantine, which is what is happening to some people who have been exposed to this new bug. Dr. Baruch-Fishoff is a professor at Carnegie Mellon University and an expert on public perception of risk and human judgment and decision-making. Welcome, Dr. Fishoff. Thank you for having me. And thank you and APA for taking on this
据美国疾病控制与预防中心估计，今年美国已有10,000人死于流感，1900万人患病。为什么我们对这种新型冠状病毒如此恐惧，而我们感染流感的可能性却大得多？本期节目的嘉宾将解释为什么我们对新风险的担忧超过了对熟悉风险的担忧，如何缓解我们的焦虑，以及被隔离——也就是一些接触过这种新病毒的人正在经历的事情——会产生什么样的心理影响。巴鲁克·费肖夫博士是卡内基梅隆大学的教授，也是公共风险感知以及人类判断与决策方面的专家。欢迎您，费肖夫博士。谢谢你邀请我。也感谢你和美国心理学会关注这个
issue. Absolutely. We're happy to have you here today. Dr. Fishoff, as I just shared, we know that the seasonal flu has sickened and killed way more people in the U.S. than this novel coronavirus. But can you explain why Americans are fearful of this new virus that's out there? Well, we don't really know how fearful Americans are. There's no systematic research as far as I know. So I can only answer based on my own observations and experience with other health health pandemic, some of which I've had an opportunity to work on. The difference or a major difference between, seasonal flu and coronavirus or other pandemics is that we understand seasonal flu very well. In fact, we're part of a project sponsored by CDC trying to get our predictions of seasonal
议题。当然。很高兴今天你能来。费肖夫博士，正如我刚才分享的，我们知道季节性流感在美国导致患病和死亡的人数远超这种新型冠状病毒。但你能解释一下为什么美国人对这种新出现的病毒感到恐惧吗？嗯，我们并不真正了解美国人有多恐惧。据我所知，目前还没有系统的研究。所以我只能根据我自己的观察和处理其他健康大流行的经验来回答，其中一些我曾有机会参与其中。季节性流感与冠状病毒或其他大流行病之间的一个区别，或者说主要区别在于，我们非常了解季节性流感。事实上，我们正在参与一个由疾控中心赞助的项目，试图让我们的季节性
flu even more accurate. Whereas with coronavirus, we don't know where it's going. So the fact that we have had no deaths in the United States as yet is only a weak indicator of what the problem is going to be. And that projection will depend on two things that public health officials are still investigating. One is how transmissible the virus is among people who are asymptomatic. And second, how effective our public health measures will be. How can people manage their anxiety about this?
流感预测更加准确。而对于冠状病毒，我们不知道它会走向何方。因此，我们在美国目前还没有死亡病例这一事实，只是衡量未来问题严重程度的一个微弱指标。而这种预测将取决于公共卫生官员仍在调查的两件事。一是病毒在无症状感染者之间的传播能力。二是我们的公共卫生措施将有多有效。人们该如何管理对这件事的焦虑呢？
I mean, you see all these news stories, information on social media. It's hard not to get wrapped up in being worried about it. So if you're here in the U.S. or in a country that's not severely impacted like China, how can you manage your anxiety around this novel virus? I think the most useful thing that people can do at this stage is to find some trusted sources of information, like the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention or the World Health Organization or some of our major media, and just stick to them for information. And that will, you know, they're professionals.
我的意思是，你看到了所有这些新闻报道和社交媒体上的信息。很难不陷入对它的担忧之中。所以，如果你在美国或像中国这样没有受到严重影响的国家，你该如何管理围绕这种新型病毒的焦虑呢？我认为人们在这个阶段能做的最有用的事情就是找到一些值得信赖的信息来源，比如疾病控制与预防中心、世界卫生组织或我们的一些主流媒体，并坚持从这些渠道获取信息。而且，你知道，他们是专业人士。
They do the best job they can of gathering and communicating the information. And that will also protect you from, you know, from the irresponsible, the rumor mongers, the people who are using this as an opportunity to, you know, to sell things or to inflame racial hatred or ethnic hatred. So I think find a few good sources of information. If they tell you that the virus is still remote and they give you confident that our public health officials have the resources and the freedom to deal with this in a professional professional way, then you can afford to monitor it until they tell you something else. Yeah, I want to touch a little more about how the role of racism or xenophobia and all this. I mean, I recall similar panic about SARS and avian flu outbreaks. And just a few years ago, we were in panic mode about Ebola, which originated in Africa.
他们尽其所能收集和传播信息。这也将保护你免受那些不负责任的人、散布谣言的人以及那些利用这个机会兜售商品或煽动种族仇恨或民族仇恨的人的影响。所以我认为，找到几个好的信息来源。如果他们告诉你病毒的威胁仍然很遥远，并且让你相信我们的公共卫生官员有资源和自由以专业的方式处理这个问题，那么你可以先观察，直到他们告诉你其他情况。是的，我想多谈谈种族主义或仇外心理在这一切中的作用。我的意思是，我记得关于非典和禽流感爆发时的类似恐慌。就在几年前，我们还对起源于非洲的埃博拉病毒处于恐慌模式。
So how do you think that plays into all how people are reacting and these, like you said, the rumors you might fall prey to, that sort of thing. When a health problem like Ebola or coronavirus comes from abroad, we have poorer information about it than we do about health problems in this country. Often foreign places have poorer surveillance capability, so they just get. have the poor information. Sometimes they have authoritarian regimes who suppress the information. So we have greater uncertainty about things that come from places with poor information.
那么你认为这在人们的反应以及你所说的你可能会上当受骗的谣言等方面起到了什么作用？当埃博拉或冠状病毒这样的健康问题来自国外时，我们掌握的信息比国内的健康问题要少。通常外国地区的监测能力较差，所以他们掌握的信息也较少。有时他们有威权政权来压制信息。因此，对于来自信息匮乏地区的事情，我们有更大的不确定性。
We also are vulnerable to people who have other access to grind seizing on this situation as a way to, as an opportunity to inflame xenophobia, fear of other ethnic groups. And, you know, we as individuals need to be above that, and we need to expect our leaders to calm them, to calm any of those fears and to stand up for people who are being unjustly criticized. I would say my university at Carnegie Mellon, I give our leadership a lot of credit. They've been on top of this issue from the very, very beginning. they've provided psychological support and practical support for people who've come back from China during the, who are in China during the winter break and might have a slightly higher probability of being affected.
我们也容易受到那些别有用心的人的影响，他们抓住这种情况作为煽动仇外心理和对其他族群恐惧的机会。而且，你知道，我们作为个人需要超越这一点，我们需要期待我们的领导人去平息这些恐惧，并为那些受到不公正批评的人挺身而出。我想说，在我的大学卡内基梅隆大学，我非常赞赏我们的领导层。他们从一开始就非常重视这个问题。他们为寒假期间在中国、可能感染概率略高的人员提供了心理支持和实际支持。
So I think we need that kind of leadership throughout the country. And why do you think we are more afraid of something we don't know than we are of something we know? I mean, I think as I say that, I'm sort of like, okay, I see why people are worried about something they don't know. But can you get into the psychological reasons why this is the case? Well, putting on my risk analyst hat, I would say we have a poorer understanding of new viruses than we have of old viruses. The course of seasonal flu is pretty well predicted. We're part of a project sponsored by CDC that's getting those predictions even better. Whereas with coronavirus, we don't know where it's capable of going.
所以我认为我们需要全国范围内都有这种领导力。你认为为什么我们对未知事物的恐惧比对已知事物的恐惧更强烈？我的意思是，当我这么说的时候，我有点明白为什么人们会担心未知的事物。但你能深入探讨一下这背后的心理原因吗？嗯，戴上我的风险分析师的帽子，我会说我们对新病毒的了解比对旧病毒的了解要少。季节性流感的进程是可以很好预测的。我们正在参与一个由疾控中心赞助的项目，该项目正在使这些预测变得更好。而对于冠状病毒，我们不知道它会发展到什么程度。
If you follow the public health literature, there's a vigorous debate about the effectiveness of the kind of quarantines that our country, the United States has. And there's a vigorous debate about whether the virus is transmissible when people are asymptomatic. If that's the case, then it's going to be harder to control it. And there's a lot of concern and legitimate concern about the public health officials about how much has, you know, how widely the disease was spread during the period in which the Chinese public health officials did not respond effectively, in part because of their political regime. Do you think some of the reactions we've seen, I'm talking about Americans being evacuated from China, canceling flights to and from China. The State Department has issued a travel warning against people going to China as well. Do you think those are warranted in this time we're in right now where there's a lot we don't understand about coronavirus? I would hope that those decisions are made on public health
如果你关注公共卫生文献，关于我国（美国）所采取的那种隔离措施的有效性存在激烈的争论。关于病毒在无症状时是否具有传染性，也存在激烈的争论。如果是这样的话，那么控制它就会更加困难。而且，公共卫生官员非常担心，在中国公共卫生官员因其政治体制而未能有效应对的期间，这种疾病传播得有多广泛。你认为我们所看到的一些反应，比如美国人从中国撤离、取消往返中国的航班，是合理的吗？国务院也发布了针对前往中国的人的旅行警告。你认为在目前我们对冠状病毒了解甚少的情况下，这些措施是合理的吗？我希望这些决定是基于公共卫生
grounds rather than political grounds. Sometimes leaders will do dramatic things in order to present themselves as what they view as leaders in ways that. that are ineffective. So the research on quarantines is that they're often ineffective unless they're accompanied by strong support for the people whose lives have been interrupted by the quarantines. That is, they need material support. If they're not able to work and living paycheck to paycheck
而非政治理由。有时领导人会采取戏剧性的行动，以展示他们自认为是领导者的形象，但这些方式往往是无效的。关于隔离的研究表明，除非伴随着对那些生活被隔离打断的人们的强力支持，否则它们往往是无效的。也就是说，他们需要物质支持。如果他们无法工作，且靠薪水过活
or gig to gig, somebody they need help in doing that. and they need it to be treated respectfully. If individuals fear that they're being not treated well, or countries feel as though they're not treated well, people will get around the vaccines or set a higher threshold for saying, you know, I'm not feeling so well, maybe I'm going to quarantine ourselves.
或者靠零工为生，他们需要帮助。而且他们需要得到尊重。如果个人担心自己没有得到很好的对待，或者国家觉得他们没有得到很好的对待，人们就会绕过疫苗，或者在说“我感觉不太好，也许我应该自我隔离”时设定更高的门槛。
There's also risk if we rely on quarantines, that we will have opportunity costs of not doing other things that are more effective. As we feel, well, this takes care of the problem. You know, as you may know, in the last two or three years, there have been substantial cutbacks in the U.S. ability, capability for surveillance for pandemics. global health was demoted in its importance on the National Security Council. So if we aren't providing those, you know, if we're relying on quarantines and not providing our public health officials with the resources and autonomy that they need, we, you know, we may be creating problems down the road. And what about the shutting down of the Chinese city of Wuhan, which is the ground zero?
如果我们依赖隔离，也会有不去做其他更有效事情的机会成本。因为我们觉得，这解决了问题。你知道，正如你可能知道的那样，在过去两三年里，美国应对大流行的监测能力大幅缩减。全球卫生在国家安全委员会中的重要性被降低了。所以，如果我们不提供这些，如果我们依赖隔离，而不给我们的公共卫生官员提供他们所需的资源和自主权，我们可能会在未来制造问题。那么，关闭作为冠状病毒震中的中国城市武汉呢？
for the coronavirus. What kind of psychological effects could that have on the citizens? When often hears a claim that people are panicking and the people who study panic, which more sociologists than psychologists,
这对市民会产生什么样的心理影响？人们经常声称人们在恐慌，而研究恐慌的人——社会学家比心理学家更多——
find that actual panics are rare. You see them more in movies than you actually see them in real life. Then under crisis situations, people typically rally around one another, they support one another, they act, they act bravely.
发现真正的恐慌是罕见的。你在电影中看到的比在现实生活中看到的要多。在危机情况下，人们通常会团结一致，互相支持，表现得勇敢。
You can disrupt that if you deprive people of the opportunity to act in a coordinated way. Like if there are no trusted sources of information, then you get more, less coordinated information. I think the tragic situation of the people in Wuhan that are experiencing is a result of a, of a, I guess a political regime that didn't allow public health people to do their work. And then the problem got out of control. And then these draconian measures were implemented. And you would have to ask an epidemiologist just how effective this is likely to be. And what is the problem of the, I've seen an estimate of five million people.
如果你剥夺了人们以协调方式行动的机会，你就会破坏这一点。比如，如果没有可信的信息来源，那么你得到的信息就会更加混乱。我认为武汉人民正在经历的悲剧性局面，是一个不允许公共卫生人员开展工作的政治体制的结果。然后问题失控了。接着实施了这些严厉的措施。你得去问流行病学家这到底有多有效。那么，关于我看到的五百万人的估计，有什么问题吗？
people who left Wuhan during the time in which the response was paralyzed. You mean they left and then she was talking about it getting, you know, essentially out of the city limits? That's right. They left the city and some of them are out there and some of them are, you know, let's hope that very few of them are sick and that they're able to get better health care than they are than the people in Wuhan have who, from what I understand, that their local health officials just don't have the surge capacity.
在应对措施瘫痪期间离开武汉的人。你是说他们离开了，然后她谈到它基本上超出了城市范围？没错。他们离开了城市，其中一些人在外面，其中一些人，让我们希望他们中很少有人生病，并且他们能够获得比武汉人民更好的医疗保健，据我所知，当地卫生官员只是没有激增的应对能力。
to handle a pandemic. So people who are sick go from hospital to hospital and being unable to be treated. People who are sick with things other than than coronavirus but are uncertain maybe going to places where they're exposing themselves either to that or to or or to or to other things. So that's a reflection of a public health system that's been under under resourced. things that you would wonder about, you know, that I would wonder about in this country is, you know, how good is our surveillance capacity with the recent cuts?
来处理大流行。所以生病的人从一家医院转到另一家医院，却无法得到治疗。患有冠状病毒以外疾病的人，由于不确定，可能会去一些地方，在那里他们要么接触到那种病毒，要么接触到其他东西。所以这反映了一个资源不足的公共卫生系统。你会想到的事情，我在这个国家会想到的事情是，你知道，在最近的削减之后，我们的监测能力有多好？
What are we prepared? How are we responding to the disruption in the supply chain for basic medical supplies, including the masks that will be needed by health care officials if we have more of a pandemic, more of a pandemic here. Yeah, I imagine it's also very tough for people who are, you know, if their lives are put on hold there and they're, you know, healthy in a place like Wuhan, you know, that's, I'm sure that's a met very challenging as they wait for information. Yeah.
我们准备好了吗？我们如何应对基本医疗用品供应链的中断，包括如果我们在国内出现更多大流行，卫生官员所需的口罩。是的，我想对于那些生活被搁置的人来说，这也非常艰难，如果他们是在武汉这样的地方，你知道，那肯定是非常具有挑战性的，因为他们在等待信息。是的。
So I don't think it's something we've, I mean, maybe we've experienced here in the U.S., but seems pretty novel to me in terms of what I know about how we respond to illnesses here. So now moving into America, you know, as we speak, there's a lot of. about 350 Americans who are in quarantine on military bases. And from what I was reading, it's people who came from China, came from flights. They had to keep them in quarantine for a couple weeks. I was reading about two weeks just to monitor them, make sure they didn't have symptoms. And the interesting thing about this, and we certainly have a lot of info about how people are doing, they seem to be not doing too badly. The New York Times was saying the people in quarantine
所以我认为这不是我们经历过的，我的意思是，也许我们在美国经历过，但就我所知我们在这里应对疾病的方式而言，这对我来说似乎非常新颖。所以现在转向美国，你知道，就在我们说话的时候，有很多关于大约350名在军事基地被隔离的美国人的消息。据我所读到的，他们是从中国回来的人，乘坐航班回来的。他们必须让他们隔离几周。我读到的是两周，只是为了监测他们，确保他们没有症状。关于这一点有趣的是，我们当然有很多关于人们情况的信息，他们似乎做得还不错。《纽约时报》说被隔离的人
have access to television, they're getting gourmet coffee, pizza, all that stuff. So it doesn't seem to be too bad. I mean, I'm sure it's probably still a little frightening. But, you know, despite the fun, I'm sure there could be lasting psychological effects of being, you know, shuttled from the plane into a military base and being under surveillance, you know, being their temperatures checked every couple hours or so, whatever it happens there. So I imagine some people probably have anxiety about it, even if they feel fine. Do you know the effects of a quarantine on someone?
可以看电视，他们有美味的咖啡、披萨，所有这些东西。所以看起来还不算太糟。我的意思是，我肯定这可能仍然有点吓人。但是，你知道，尽管有这些乐趣，我肯定从飞机上被转移到军事基地并处于监视之下，你知道，每隔几个小时检查一次体温，无论那里发生了什么，都可能会产生持久的心理影响。所以我猜有些人即使感觉良好，可能也会对此感到焦虑。你知道隔离对某人的影响吗？
So my understanding of the research on that kind of, of, of, stress is that there will be people who are, who have related traumas in their lives before that any stressful event, they're more vulnerable to any stressful event. So I think if one did a systematic interview person by person, you would find some variability. And you would also find that some people whose lives are more disrupted than others if they're responsible for vulnerable family members or if they are living, if they don't have the economic ability to withstand the loss of income for this period of time. I think what one sees superficially at a group level is what people usually do. They're resilient. They're mutually supportive. They rally to one another.
据我对那种压力的研究的理解，会有一些人之前在生活中经历过相关的创伤，他们对任何压力事件都更脆弱。所以我认为如果一个人对每个人进行系统的采访，你会发现一些差异。你还会发现，如果他们负责照顾脆弱的家庭成员，或者如果他们生活在没有经济能力承受这段时间收入损失的情况下，一些人的生活比其他人受到的干扰更大。我认为一个人在群体层面上表面上看到的是人们通常所做的。他们有韧性。他们互相支持。他们团结在一起。
They try to make the best of a bad situation. And if we rely on people's natural resilience and if the authorities treat them in a respectful way and attend to their material needs as well as they can, one would expect most people to, I believe, to get through it well. I did find a study in the journal Emerging Infectious Diseases that studied 129 people who were quarantined with SARS. That was in the early 2000s, I believe. And they found that many had psychological distress, including post-traumatic stress, disorder and depression.
他们试图在糟糕的情况下做到最好。如果我们依赖人们的自然韧性，如果当局以尊重的态度对待他们，并尽可能地照顾他们的物质需求，人们会期望大多数人，我相信，能很好地度过难关。我确实在《新发传染病》杂志上找到了一项研究，研究了129名因非典被隔离的人。我相信那是在21世纪初。他们发现许多人有心理困扰，包括创伤后应激障碍和抑郁症。
And I found that the longer someone was quarantined, the higher likelihood that he or she would experience PTSD symptoms. So obviously this shows that being isolated from others can bring up a host of negative feelings. Yeah. Why would you think PSD symptoms would be so high? Well, so SARS is different than, uh, different than coronavirus, you know, at this moment in that SARS had a much higher case fatality rate.
我发现一个人被隔离的时间越长，他或她经历创伤后应激障碍症状的可能性就越高。所以很明显，这表明与他人隔绝会带来一系列负面情绪。是的。你为什么认为创伤后应激障碍症状会如此之高？嗯，所以非典与冠状病毒不同，你知道，在这一刻，非典的病死率要高得多。
if the people were quarantined and either had symptoms or thought that they might get sick, there was a lot of legitimate anxiety. There was more people were dying. We didn't have a cure at that time or better cures at that time. And I suspect that the treatment, the social treatment might have been more stigmatized. and the longer you are isolated from your normal life, the more disrupted is, the more your vulnerabilities are being tested. And the more things that go wrong in the life that you're not able to keep together.
如果人们被隔离并且要么有症状，要么认为他们可能会生病，就会有许多合理的焦虑。有更多的人在死亡。我们当时没有治愈方法，或者当时没有更好的治愈方法。而且我怀疑这种待遇，社会待遇可能更具污名化。而且你与正常生活隔绝的时间越长，干扰就越大，你的脆弱性就越受到考验。而且你在生活中无法保持在一起的事情就越多。
We all have a day-to-day challenge of keeping our lives together. So I think the combination of not knowing where this was going, which had legitimate the fears of which are much greater than the people who are currently quarantined in the U.S. regarding coronavirus and the longer, you know, disruption would have either triggered vulnerabilities, particularly people who are vulnerable already. It's interesting. And it also found that being an acquaintance or having direct exposure to someone with SARS was also associated with PTSD and depression.
我们都有保持生活在一起的日常挑战。所以我认为不知道这会走向何方的结合，其合理的恐惧远大于目前在美国因冠状病毒被隔离的人，以及更长的，你知道，干扰会触发脆弱性，特别是那些已经脆弱的人。这很有趣。而且它还发现，成为熟人或与非典患者有直接接触也与创伤后应激障碍和抑郁症有关。
Why would, why do you think that would be the case? So again, this is not my specialty, but from my understanding of that research literature for people that I've worked with is that maybe it's just a common sense result. You know, there are people we love and we care about them and we're anxious whenever they're sick. And in some ways, we're even more powerless than they are. They can, you know, they can rally and we can just worry. it seems like a normal, in some ways, a healthy human reaction that takes a toll. Yeah, that makes a lot of sense. I'm sure it's very difficult, especially in those situations, someone being quarantined.
你为什么认为会这样呢？所以同样，这不是我的专业，但根据我对那些我合作过的人的研究文献的理解，也许这只是一个常识性的结果。你知道，有我们爱和关心的人，每当他们生病时我们都会感到焦虑。在某些方面，我们甚至比他们更无能为力。他们可以，你知道，他们可以振作起来，而我们只能担心。这似乎是一种正常的，在某些方面，一种健康的、付出代价的人类反应。是的，这很有道理。我肯定这非常困难，特别是在那些情况下，有人被隔离。
There was a lot of fear at that time when SARS was out. So going back to the public health response, what is your perception of the public health, how officials are responding to it? They sort of seem like, I mean, there's a lot that's not known. And I understand, you know, there'll be meetings coming up. soon to talk about what we know about this virus, that sort of thing. But do you think they're in panic mode? I mean, obviously we've been through SARS, the avian flu, Ebola, swine flu, that sort of thing.
非典流行时，当时有很多恐惧。所以回到公共卫生应对措施，你对公共卫生官员如何应对它的看法是什么？他们看起来好像，我的意思是，有很多未知的东西。而且我理解，你知道，很快会有会议来讨论我们对这种病毒的了解，诸如此类的事情。但你认为他们处于恐慌模式吗？我的意思是，显然我们经历过非典、禽流感、埃博拉、猪流感，诸如此类的事情。
So what is your perception of what, how public officials are responding? I would say if panic is rare among the general public, it's almost non-existent among public health officials. They are the most idealistic, toughest, bravest, hard-wrest, hard-word. profession that you can that you can imagine. I think they're under a lot of pressure to deal with this. Deal with this. They have very few resources, which again have been cut back over the recent period. What I would like to see more from them is a more scientific approach to communication.
所以你对公共官员如何应对的看法是什么？我会说如果恐慌在公众中是罕见的，那么在公共卫生官员中几乎是不存在的。他们是你所能想象到的最理想主义、最坚强、最勇敢、最努力的职业。我认为他们在处理这个问题上承受着巨大的压力。处理这个问题。他们几乎没有资源，这些资源在最近一段时间再次被削减。我希望从他们那里看到更多的是一种更科学的沟通方法。
That is when we, you know, a scientific approach to risk communication would be starting, analyzing the decisions that people face, finding out what information is most critical to them, finding out what they currently believe, creating, drafting messages based on what we already know about how to communicate different things, and then testing those messages. And I don't have a sense that they're, you know, very well-intended messages, say at places like WHO or CDC have that rigor. So, for example, a question that is a specific decision that has occurred to many people is, should I be stocking face masks? And so what do I need to know in order to answer that question is one is, one is, how effective are face masks for today's risks, and will face masks be available should the risk
也就是说，当我们，你知道，一种科学的风险沟通方法将是开始分析人们面临的决定，找出对他们来说最关键的信息，找出他们目前相信什么，创建、起草基于我们已经知道的关于如何沟通不同事物的消息，然后测试这些消息。而且我没有感觉到他们，你知道，在世界卫生组织或疾控中心等地方非常善意的消息具有那种严谨性。所以，例如，一个许多人都遇到的具体决定问题是，我应该储备口罩吗？所以我需要知道什么才能回答这个问题，一是，一是，口罩对今天的风险有多有效，如果风险变得更大，口罩会有吗？
get greater? It's my understanding, not being a medical doctor, that face masks are not particularly effective even in, you know, even where they're not needed now, and they're actually not particularly effective unless you have a very high quality to protect yourself unless you have a very high quality face masks and are well trained and well disciplined and taking it on putting it on and taking it off that face masks will if you're sick with cold or flu or anything you can help to protect other other people but if you're worried about protecting yourself and you're not a health official you probably don't need to worry about it whether we will have face so what about in the future? So let's say there is flu and they will be useful and I think that I could
据我了解，不是医学博士，口罩即使在，你知道，即使在现在不需要的地方也不是特别有效，而且除非你有高质量的口罩来保护自己，除非你有高质量的口罩并且受过良好训练和纪律严明，在戴上和取下时，口罩如果如果你患有感冒或流感或任何东西，你可以帮助保护其他人，但如果你担心保护自己，而你不是卫生官员，你可能不需要担心它。那么未来呢？所以假设有流感，它们会有用，我想我可以
diligently put it on and take it off. Then it's really a question of who are the institutions that are responsible for ensuring that we have an adequate supply of FACTS, and they are distributed to the people who need them most. So for that, I need to be looking at, I don't know, the Department of Health and Human Services and see whether they are. there are people that I trust to handle this situation. And just as we close out, I want to summarize for our listeners just what they should take away from this. Can you talk about, can you just give me a few points they can take away from this podcast as they see how this virus plays out and how they might be managing how to manage their anxiety?
勤奋地戴上和取下它。那么这真的是一个关于谁是负责确保我们有充足口罩供应的机构的问题，并且它们被分发给最需要它们的人。所以对于这一点，我需要关注，我不知道，卫生与公众服务部，看看他们是否是。有我信任的人来处理这种情况。在结束时，我想为我们的听众总结一下他们应该从中得到什么。你能谈谈，你能给我几个要点，让他们从这个播客中带走，因为他们看到这种病毒如何发展，以及他们可能如何管理如何管理他们的焦虑吗？
I think the first thing that people can do is to find a trusted source of information and just follow that. That will insulate them from rumors, and that will help them to get to have a clear picture and see how things are changed. Second thing is you can do, you know, a very simple risk analysis, which is to say, is there any reason to think that I am at risk? Are there cases where I am? Have I, if there are, have I come in contact with them? And third thing you could do is do a simple risk management, which is to figure out what are the few things that you can do most effectively. And if you go to these trusted sources, they will tell you that you should wash your hands really well and you should maintain a distance from somebody who might have the flu. And then you should avoid becoming a source of risk to other people by information.
我认为人们能做的第一件事就是找到一个可信的信息来源，并坚持关注它。这将使他们免受谣言的影响，并将帮助他们获得清晰的画面，看看事情是如何变化的。第二件事你可以做，你知道，一个非常简单的风险分析，那就是说，有什么理由认为我处于危险之中吗？有我处于危险之中的情况吗？我有，如果有，我接触过他们吗？第三件事你可以做的是做一个简单的风险管理，那就是弄清楚你可以最有效地做的几件事。如果你去这些可信的来源，他们会告诉你，你应该洗手洗得很好，你应该与可能患有流感的人保持距离。然后你应该避免通过信息成为对他人的风险来源。
insulating yourself if you're if you're sick, coughing into your sleeve, using a tissue, and throwing it out. So that will, if you do those three things, it will get you most of the information that you need and it will enable you to play a responsible role and getting on top of all of this. And it will protect you from seasonal flu, which at the moment is a bigger, bigger risk than coronavirus is and we hope the coronavirus ever will be. And maybe the fourth thing I would add is to be supportive of people who are under greater stress. So those will be people who, for whom, you know, who do have anxiety that's been triggered by
如果你生病了就隔离自己，对着袖子咳嗽，使用纸巾，然后扔掉。所以，如果你做这三件事，它将为你提供你需要的大部分信息，它将使你能够发挥负责任的作用，并掌控这一切。它将保护你免受季节性流感的影响，目前季节性流感比冠状病毒风险更大，我们希望冠状病毒永远不会达到那种程度。也许我要补充的第四点是支持那些承受更大压力的人。所以那些将是那些，对于他们来说，你知道，确实有焦虑被触发的人
this or people who do feel like they've been discriminated or are worried about, about loved ones. And those are good things that we hope that we all do anyways. Thank you so much for those tips, Dr. Fishoff. I think that will be very helpful. I think this will help calm people's anxiety and, you know, help ease some of the worry that's out there. I appreciate your time.
因为这个，或者那些确实觉得他们受到歧视或担心亲人的人。这些是我们希望我们无论如何都会做的好事。非常感谢你的这些建议，费肖夫博士。我认为这将非常有帮助。我认为这将有助于平息人们的焦虑，你知道，有助于缓解外面的一些担忧。我很感激你的时间。
Oh, thank you for, thank you for opportunity to talk with you. Yeah. And to our listeners, thanks for tuning in. Don't forget to let us know what you think about our podcast. You can email your comments and ideas to speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word.org. And please give us a rating in iTunes. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts.
哦，谢谢你，谢谢你给我机会和你交谈。是的。对于我们的听众，感谢收听。别忘了让我们知道你对我们播客的看法。你可以通过电子邮件将你的评论和想法发送到 speaking of psychology at APA.org。那是 speaking of psychology，所有单词连在一起.org。请在 iTunes 上给我们评分。你可以在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。
You can also go to our website speakingofpsychology.org to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. Thanks for listening. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你也可以访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 收听更多节目。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。感谢收听。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。